Approchons-nous de cette petite planète
qui, a priori, n'a rien d'extraordinaire.
Code 05390
Nous glissons à la surface de son sol gelé,
mais nous allons avoir une surprise...
Prenons une planète aussi glacée et elle est
très loin de son étoile, très froide.
Malheureusement, il n'y a pas de vie
sur une telle planète, mais par contre,
il doit y avoir un ciel absolument superbe.
Pourquoi ?
Dans les régions centrales de la galaxie,
la densité d'étoiles est beaucoup plus grande,
peut-être 1 million de fois plus grande,
voire plus, que dans notre voisinage.
Imaginons le ciel que l'on doit avoir vu depuis
une telle planète : une myriade d'étoiles,
100 fois, 1000 fois plus de beau fond du ciel
que celui qu'on a sur terre.
Malheureusement, on ne pourra pas y aller.
Alors bien sûr, ce que cherchent les astronomes,
c'est une nouvelle terre.
Mais où donc la trouver ?
On aimerait une petite planète, un peu comme
la Terre et qui soit à la bonne distance
pour qu'il fasse ni trop chaud ni trop froid
et Gliese 581 D est la première petit planète
qui se trouve dans cette situation.
Ce n'est pas encore une planète comme la Terre.
Elle fait sept fois la masse de la Terre.
encore un peu trop lourd, mais elle est dans
la zone habitable de son étoile.
Michel Mayor émet aujourd'hui une hypothèse
très personnelle sur Gliese 581 d.
Planète,océan. Pour Michel Mayor, ce serait à
l'origine une planète glacée qui aurait migré
et fondu tout près de son étoile.
Et le résultat, c'est un immense océan.
Rien à voir avec l'océan extrêmement fin que
l'on connaît sur Terre, mais réellement
un océan peut-être de 100 Km de profondeur.
À présent, voici un objet incroyable :
PSR B 1257+12 qui a une fantastique histoire.
Cette petite planète orbite autour d'un pulsar,
un cadavre d'étoile qui tourbillonne en émettant
un jet très intense de rayons X et ultraviolet.
Elle fut détectée en 1990 par deux astronomes
polonais, 5 ans avant la découverte officielle
de Michel Mayor. Mais à cette époque,
les astronomes n'étaient pas certain
qu'il pouvait s'agir d'une véritable planète.
Ils avaient tort : ce fut la première exoplanète
jamais découverte.
L'équipe de Corot, elle, vient de trouver la plus
petite planète connue à ce jour : CoRoT-7b.
À peine plus grosse que la Terre, elle tourne
en moins de 24 h autour de son étoile.
C'est-à-dire que si CoRoT-7b avait des habitants
l'année durerait moins d'un jour...
Ça ressemble à l'histoire du Petit Prince.
Comme elle tourne autour de son étoile
en moins d'un jour, elle est très très proche
de son étoile, très proche du feu,
donc il y fait très très chaud.
Mais comme elle montre toujours la même face
à son étoile, tout comme la lune montre toujours
la même face à la Terre, CoRoT-7b est très chaude
d'un côté, et doit être très froide de l'autre.
Donc, si on doit passer d'un côté à l'autre,
il faut passer du maillot de bain
à la combinaison de ski.